[Musica]
dopo questo questa presentazione avevo
due possibilità entrare o non entrare in
ogni caso era in uno dei futuri
possibili la fisica dell'ultimo secolo
ha mostrato un antica intuizione del
misticismo orientale
ossia che il mondo lo spazio in cui
viviamo è un complicato tessuto una rete
dinamica pulsante di eventi citando le
parole di carlo rovelli non solo le cose
possono entrare in relazione ma sono
proprio le relazioni che determinano la
nozione di cosa io sono un ricercatore
dell'università di udine mi occupo
diretti guarda caso le reti sono un
modello estremamente semplice lineare
appagante ma anche onnipresente internet
il web
le reti sociali il nostro cervello
ciò che mi affascina di questo modello
delle reti è che contengono includono al
loro interno tre modelli interessanti
che cercherò di illustrarvi in questa
presentazione modello lineare
il modello ramificato e il modello
circolare e sono tutti rappresentati in
questo in questa rete o anche grafo come
lo chiamano i matematici
partiamo dal modello lineare che cos'è
il modello lineare modello lineare è una
successione incessante senza possibilità
di alternative distanti corrisponde al
concetto di fatalismo e può essere
visualizzata mediante un cammino un
cammino quindi una successione di punti
vi spiegherò questo modello usando
l'idea il fenomeno dei sei gradi di
separazione
qualcuno conosce la teoria del piccolo
mondo beh forse i miei studenti si visto
che l'ha insegnata quest'anno e ce ne
sono qui presenti
la teoria del piccolo mondo ci dice
questo
prendete una persona a caso sul pianeta
terra
un meccanico di tijuana in messico o un
fruttivendolo di perth in australia
quanti gradi di separazione ci separano
da queste persone se conoscessi
direttamente il meccanico ci sarebbe un
grado di separazione
se lo conoscessi indirettamente tramite
un'altra persona magari un mio amico che
studia in messico ci sarebbero due gradi
separazione e così via
il fenomeno del piccolo mondo ci dice
che nonostante il mondo sia grande la
rete sia vastissima in termini di un
numero di nodi di attori le distanze tra
persone tra attori sono molto piccoli in
matematica diciamo che sono logaritmiche
nel numero di nodi su quindi molto qui
agli inizi del secolo scorso nel 1929
uno scrittore semisconosciuto offri che
stare in chi scrive un racconto
intitolato chains catene
da qui ha estratto questo paragrafo lui
immagina di scegliere a caso una persona
tra il miliardo e mezzo che vivono che
vivevano allora sulla terra e scommette
che non con un più di cinque individui
intermedi cioè non più di sei passaggi
lui riesce a raggiungere mediante la
rete di conoscenze questa persona è il
primo a intuire questo fenomeno però lav
intuisce a livello letterario nel senso
che lascia una intuizione di pura
fantasia
per me è sorprendente che 40 anni dopo c
nel 1967 uno psicologo americano stanley
milgram molto famoso conduce il suo
famoso esperimento sul piccolo mondo e
in un certo senso conferma l'intuizione
di cali cosa fa milgram prende l'elenco
telefonico non c'era internet allora
sceglie a caso un centinaio di persone e
chiede a queste persone di inviare una
lettera un pacchetto un plico a un
destinatario che vive a mille chilometri
di distanza
devono inviare però attraverso la rete
di conoscenze personali
alla fine si reca dal suo amico
raccoglie le lettere a rifatte
naturalmente alcune si sono perse per
strada sulle lettere sono stati annotati
tutti i passaggi di queste catene di
questi cammini calcola la media dei
cammini e le lunghezze di questi cammini
esce il numero 6 cioè in realtà 5.9 da
qui il mito dei sei gradi di separazione
questa ipotesi questa idea del piccolo
mondo quindi del fatto che il mondo
nonostante sia molto grande è connesso
da distanze molto piccole tra tra gli
individui è poi stata ripetuta è stata
confermata recentemente in un
esperimento un lavoro fatto per altro in
collaborazione col politecnico di milano
sulla rete facebook usando un campione
molto più grande di quello usato da
milgram un campione di un miliardo e
mezzo di persone proprio lo stesso i
numeri che ritornano lo stesso numero di
persone che carenti immaginava sul
pianeta terra 80 anni prima il gra di
separazione sono diminuiti sono oggi 4.5
il secondo modello di cui vorrei
parlarvi a modello ramificato implementa
realizza il concetto di libero arbitrio
e può essere rappresentato mediante un
albero i punti di scelta e cammini
futuri possibili un giardino di sentieri
che si biforcano potremmo dire
il ragionamento temporale e qui parliamo
di tempo ha origini molto antiche risale
proprio ai filosofi greci aristotele è
il primo a interrogarsi su questioni
temporali con il problema pone il
problema dei futuri contingenti persone
futili contingenti sono proposizioni che
si riferiscono a eventi futuri
aristotele si chiede prendiamo questa
proposizione ci sarà domani una
battaglia navale
oppure riformulata ai tempi odierni ci
sarà un terremoto domani o domani
sorgerà il sole agli state le si chiede
possiamo noi definire un valore di
verità in una logica binaria vero falso
per queste affermazioni oggi possiamo
dire che oggi queste affermazioni sono
vere o false nella sua semplice saggezza
mia madre direbbe che solo il signore sa
la risposta e alcuni secoli dopo
guglielmo di ockham non disse cose molto
diverse
con tutto il rispetto la risposta di sé
sta nella mente dell'uomo non sta nella
mente dell'uomo ma sta solo nella mente
di dio è in realtà ockham attribuisce
all'uomo una proprietà molto importante
la proprietà del libero arbitrio quindi
la proprietà di scegliere tra diversi
fare delle scelte e quindi creare
diverse possibilità di verso sentieri
diversi futuri possibili e questo in un
certo senso spiega da una soluzione al
problema di aristotele dei futuri
contingenti ossia queste affermazioni
non sono inconsistenti in quanto se
immaginiamo una struttura ad albero in
cui ci sono più futuri possibili come
scherzavamo all'inizio in un futuro io
mi sono presentato visto dando questo
talk in un altro sono dietro bere il mio
the rilassante
allora è perfettamente lecito che in
alcuni di questi futuri ci sia un
terremoto o una battaglia navale in
altri non ci sia
oppure in tutti questi futuri sorgerà il
sole domani o la terra finirà è curioso
come negli anni 50 un filosofo e logico
neozelandese arthur prior studia questi
questi ragionamenti soprattutto quelli
di ockham e definisce il concetto di
logica temporale di cui vedete i quattro
operatori principali della causalità
brunch in time logico la logica
temporale ramificata e la sua inter la
loro interpretazione sulle strutture
d'albero non andrò oggi però è
interessante per me farvi capire che da
queste disposizioni filosofiche che
possono sembrare
insomma superficiali per certi versi è
nata una logica che oggi ha importanti
importantissimi applicazioni in
intelligenza artificiale per esempio per
rappresentare la conoscenza temporale e
in informatica per analizzare il
comportamento dei sistemi reattivi non
deterministici ma il terzo modello di
cui vorrei raccontarvi forse quello un
po più interessante o più sorprendente è
il modello autoreferenziale o circolare
è un cammino che ritorna sui suoi passi
un ciclo diciamo in teoria dei grafi un
uroboro appunto e serpente che si mangia
la coda
l'autoreferenzialità o ricorsione in
matematica è un concetto
sorprendentemente presente in natura e
assume la forma del frattale qui vedete
il broccolo romano che oltre a essere
buonissimo e anche un perfetto
esempio di frattale che cosa trattare un
frattale è una figura geometrica che si
ripete a scale diverse sulla vostra
destra avete un immagine del frattale
del broccolo nella sua interezza alla
vostra sinistra avesse in particolare
vede che particolare assomiglia al tutto
quindi c'è questa forma e ritorno a
questa sorta di autoreferenzialità di
circolarità questa è diciamola
l'autoreferenzialità in natura questa e
l'autoreferenzialità in matematica è
sempre rischioso mostrare delle
equazioni matematiche ma matematiche in
un the talk e realtà questa equazione io
ci tengo moltissimo
innanzitutto perché un'equazione
bellissima e sfido chiunque a dire il
contrario
e questa non sia poesia e poi è
un'equazione utile da utilizzate voi
tutti i giorni
questa equazione perché l'equazione che
sta alla base di un algoritmo che si
chiama pagerank è il pagerank
l'algoritmo più utilizza google search
il motore di ricerca per ordinare le
pagine a fronte di una vostra
interrogazione a fronte di una vostra
richiesta
volendo parafrasare il significato
interpretare dare un'interpretazione a
questi simboli matematici potremmo dire
che potremo leggerla in questo modo
l'equazione dice che un attore nella
rete importante se circondata da altri
attori importanti
avete colto la circolarità della cosa
sto definendo qualcosa in termini di se
stesso un auto referenzialità quasi una
tautologia diremo in logica anche se in
realtà esiste una soluzione ben precisa
simpaticamente dove si vede la
ricorsione beh lambda numero ha una
matrice una struttura algebrica che
serve per codificare per rappresentare
la rete exan vettore quindi non potete
semplificare la x1 è qualcuno diceva
ieri sono strutture molto differenti tra
di loro
la ricorsività l'autoreferenzialità sta
nel fatto che
la ex pompare a sinistra ea destra del
segno di uguale quindi sto cercando di
definire qualcosa in termini di se
stesso
pura magia dal mio punto di vista uno
dei lavori che mi ha dato più
soddisfazione è stato quello di studiare
la storia di questa equazione pensate
studiare la storia di un'equazione a chi
era mai venuto in mente e pare che i
primi a usarla non siano stati sociologi
negli anni cinquanta affermando che una
persona prestigiosa se riceve
approvazioni da altre persone di preci
di prestigio nel 1970 è scoperta anche
in bibliometria una rivista influente se
viene citata da altre riviste influenti
negli anni 90 fa capolino anche nello
sport una squadra è forte si batte altre
squadre altrettanto forti infine negli
anni 2000 due studenti di dottorato
dell'università americana di stanford
sergey brin e larry page riscoprono per
l'ennesima volta questo mantra ricorsivo
e ne fanno il cuore pulsante di motore
di ricerca google source che diventerà
sicuramente molto popolare non era
l'unica equazione ce n'è un'altra ma è
anche l'ultima all'università di udine
abbiamo studiato una variante al signor
collega enrico bozzo una variante di
questa equazione bacco notare il
concetto di potere non di centralità non
di importanza potrebbe essere
parafrasata in questo modo un attore
importante se è circondato da attori
poco importante
anche questa è un'equazione ricorsiva
come vedete l'aic scompare a destra ea
sinistra del segno di uguale l'abbiamo
applicata in un contesto economico di
negoziazione si deve negoziare con
qualcuno il mio potere di negoziazione è
alto se i miei contraenti anno sono poco
potenti se invece i miei contraenti sono
molto potenti se i miei contraenti si
chiamano google apple microsoft era
mette il mio potere di negoziazione
molto piccolo
nel nostro caso l'abbiamo applicata alla
rete di distribuzione del gas naturale
un europa che qui vedete schematizzata
in un grafo indiretto la dimensione del
nodo è proporzionale al al potere del
nodo quindi vedete che no di grandi sono
vicini a nodi piccoli e viceversa
questo il concetto di fondo
riavvolgendo e qui si spiega anche la
mia maglietta
riavvolgendo il nostro uroboro il nostro
cammino potremo tornare all'inizio e
siamo partiti dicendo che lo spazio
l'abbiamo sentito questa mattina una
trama
la trama della realtà diceva david 8
lo spazio è una rete a una rete di
eventi perché non proporre quindi in
questo finale un'idea un po originale il
tempo come una rete la rete del tempo in
fondo il modello della della rete
contiene la linearità la ramificazione
addirittura la circolarità che hanno
sicuramente come abbiamo visto a che
fare col tempo purtroppo il margine
temporale che mi separa dalla fine di
questo intervento è troppo breve per
investigare oltre questa brillante
intuizione e magari potremmo chiedere a
qualche fisico teorico se questa
intuizione a ha senso
non mi resta altro che lasciarvi con una
delle più belle citazioni che mi siano
mai state suggerite sul tempo e augurare
a tutti la bellezza quì in questo mondo
grazie
[Applauso]